Hi.
I'm JJ Behrens.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
And I'm here to talk about
using Ruby on Rails and
YouTube for educational
applications.
So here's my goal.
I want to talk about
four things.
Ruby on Rails.
I want to talk about YouTube.
I want to talk about
education.
And I want to talk about
test-driven development.
And I want to do it all
at the same time.
This is what I call
a peanut butter,
banana, and honey sandwich.
YouTube is of course the
honey because videos
make everything sweeter.
Education is the banana because
everyone knows that
education is bananas.
Ruby on Rails is the peanut
butter because it holds
everything together.
And then test-driven development
is the bread.
Because without the bread
holding things together,
everything just falls apart.
Let me talk about YouTube EDU
first. I promise I'll get to
some more technical content
in a minute.
The goal of YouTube EDU is to
engage, educate, and inspire.
As of 2011, we had 700
educational channels, 500,000
educational videos,
and 3 billion
educational video views.
The vision of YouTube EDU is
to provide a vibrant global
platform where anyone, anywhere,
can obtain a
world-class education.
Whether you are a student,
teacher, or gifted
storyteller, our hope is that
you'll be able to continually
discover, create, and
share educational
videos with the world.
I know this is a technical talk,
but I hope you won't
mind if I show you this one
really great video about
YouTube EDU.
It's a video about YouTube
for schools.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[POPPING SOUND]
[SOUNDS OF EXCITEMENT
FROM CLASS]
-If this does not
blow your mind--
-Hola.
Buenos dias.
[INAUDIBLE]
-It is a dream deeply rooted
in the American dream.
-And we eventually
broke the code.
-Today, students, we're going
to learn about oxygen.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So let's talk about using
Ruby with YouTube APIs.
First of all, some
brutal honesty.
Let's face it, Ruby developers
are a lot more likely to talk
about Amazon APIs than they are
to talk about Google APIs.
And Google job postings are a
lot more likely to talk about
Python than they are
to talk about Ruby.
But there are a lot of us here
at Google who love Ruby.
And I want to help you overcome
the hurdles that Ruby
developers face when they start
using Google APIs in
general and YouTube
APIs specifically.
In order to pave the way, I
wrote a sample application.
Quizzimoto is a Ruby on Rails
application that I wrote for
this presentation.
It uses the YouTube APIs as
well as the Google+ APIs.
And I'm hoping to open source
it as soon as possible.
Let me show you an example
of using it.
Here we are at the
welcome screen.
And it says, Quizzimoto.
Welcome to Quizzimoto.
This application lets you build
video-based quizzes.
I'm going to hit Login
to continue.
It says, Quizzimoto is
requesting permission to
manage your YouTube account,
know who you are on Google,
and perform these operations
while I'm not using this
application.
And notice, I'm on
accounts.google.com.
I'm going to go ahead
and allow access.
So here we are at the homepage
for Quizzimoto.
It says, welcome
to Quizzimoto.
This application lets you build
video-based quizzes.
And it shows me the
available quizzes.
Each of these has a title,
a thumbnail,
an age, and a country.
So let's click on Basic
Trigonometry.
Here we have a quiz on the
left and a YouTube
video on the right.
And you could click to play the
video and then answer the
questions in the quiz.
It's a pretty simple mashup.
So let's go ahead and
edit this quiz.
We could change the name, the
minimum age, and the country.
We could select a new video.
And we could pick a new form.
I'll go ahead and search
for a video.
So this time I want to
search for geometry.
GData is used to get search
results from YouTube.
And you could pick any one
of these videos to
use with your quiz.
Now, let me show you the form.
This is actually a
Google Docs form.
And you can see here the
title of the quiz
and a bunch of questions.
The idea is that anyone could
use this form to add new
questions by clicking here on
Add Item and adding a new type
of question, such as checkboxes,
and then filling
in the question title, the
help text, and so forth.
Now, when the user completes the
quiz, all of the answers
will automatically get saved
to a spreadsheet.
And here is the spreadsheet
that the
teacher could look at.
And so we have one answer here
with the timestamp, the length
of the hypotenuse,
and so forth.
And so immediately, the teacher
could see all of the
responses that students have
filled out when they were
answering the quiz.
Now let me give you an overview
of YouTube APIs.
With GData APIs, you could
perform searches, upload
videos, create playlists,
and more.
With Player APIs, you could
control the player using
either ActionScript
3 or JavaScript.
If you'd like to learn more,
go to youtube.com/dev.
So let me give you some advice
concerning client libraries.
And I'm going to get a little
bit opinionated here.
Be skeptical of client
libraries.
They're often poorly documented
or out of date.
I think you should understand
and embrace REST APIs.
They're often very
well documented,
especially at Google.
Understand what the client
library does.
Read the documentation
and the samples.
And don't be afraid to
skim the source,
especially the tests.
I think you should use client
libraries when they make your
life easier.
Now let me share a note
about API versions.
The current version of the Data
API for YouTube is 2.1.
It's based on the GData
API infrastructure.
When the newer version of the
Data API for YouTube comes
out, it'll be version 3.
And it'll be based on a newer
API infrastructure.
Other Google APIs, such as
Google+, already use this
newer API infrastructure.
Different client libraries
support
different YouTube API versions.
So it's important that you pick
the right client library
for the right API version.
When version 3 comes out, we'll
all be able to switch to
the much nicer, more modern
client libraries that are
already in use by projects
such as Google+.
Now let me talk about the
various Google client
libraries for Ruby.
First of all, there's
google-api-ruby-client.
This automatically creates
bindings for the
newer Google APIs.
Signet is a client library
that's used by
google-api-ruby-client.
It handles things like OAuth2.
And it's also useful
for working with
older Google APIs.
Gdata-ruby-util was a client
library used for older
Gdata-based Google APIs.
It has a little bit of
YouTube-specific code.
But it doesn't include support
for OAuth2, and
it's no longer necessary.
YOUTUBE_IT is a fairly modern
third-party library.
But unfortunately, it
doesn't include
support for OAuth2 either.
Here's what Quizzimoto needed
from a client library.
First of all, I needed OAuth2.
And I needed the ability to pass
the YouTube developer key
as a custom header.
I needed support for both older
and newer Google APIs.
Here's what I used.
I used the
google-api-ruby-client for
talking to newer APIs
such as Google+.
And I used Signet for doing
OAuth2 and talking to older
APIs such as YouTube's
GData API.
So let me talk about OAuth2
because it's one of the
biggest hurdles that Ruby
developers face when they want
to build an application
for YouTube.
So you might be wondering
why you need OAuth2.
OAuth2 is an authorization
system.
Using OAuth2, you could access
an API on the user's behalf
and do things with
his account.
OAuth2 supports different
flows for
different types of apps.
There is even a flow for
non-web-enabled devices such
as Xbox 360.
Let me share with you
the bigger picture.
The user uses your app.
Your app redirects the
user to Google.
Google asks the user if your
app can access certain
services on his behalf.
Then Google redirects your app
with some information.
And your app talks to Google to
verify the authenticity of
that information.
Next, your app can use that
information to access certain
services on the user's behalf.
The important thing here is
that the user never has to
share his username and
password with your
application.
Now, the great thing about using
OAuth2 for Quizzimoto is
that I don't need to create
my own login system.
I could use OAuth2 to get
authorization to load the
user's Google+ identity, ask
the user for read access to
his Google+, and read/write
access to his YouTube.
So obviously, OAuth2 is too
large of a subject for me to
cover in 10 minutes.
But let me show you where
you can learn more.
At oauthssodemo.appspot.com, we
have a sample application
that integrates with
OpenID, which is
very related to OAuth2.
The nice thing about this
application is that it shows
you each step along the process,
along with the
parameters involved.
So here are the URLs involved.
And here are the parameters
involved.
Now let me go ahead and
click Connect Me.
So I'm going to go ahead
and sign in.
And now I'm logged in.
And it shows my profile picture,
which I decided to be
inverse, and it shows my name.
The next thing that I'd like
to show off is the OAuth2
documentation for YouTube.
Here's the URL.
And here's what it looks like.
When I first wanted to learn
about OAuth2, I knew it was a
bit of an intimidating
subject.
So I was very happy to see
documentation on it.
The documentation for YouTube
API tends to be excellent
because we have really
good tech writers.
So I read through this
from top to bottom.
And at the end, everything
just made sense.
The next thing that I'd like
to show you is the
google-api-ruby-client.
This is a library that's
on code.google.com.
Most importantly, I'd like to
show you the source code.
This is a small Sinatra
application that integrates
with OAuth2.
It's actually fairly short,
which is really nice because
it makes it easy to integrate
with your own Ruby on Rails
application or Sinatra
application.
First, let me open
up routes.rb.
We have three routes here--
oauth2_authorize,
oauth2_callback, and logout.
And these correspond
to the three steps
that you need in OAuth2.
Each of these are based on
the OAuth2 controller.
Now let me show you application
controller.
There's a lot going on in this
file, but the most important
thing is the setup
OAuth2 method.
This method was taken from the
earlier example I showed you
from the Sinatra application.
I took it and modified
it slightly.
So here we're setting up a
Google API client, with all
the authorization and HTTP
adapter stuff we need.
And basically, I just
tweaked the code
that was there earlier.
Now let me show you the
OAuth2 controller.
This class is actually
fairly short.
We have three methods--
authorize, callback,
and logout.
Authorize sets up an
authorization URI.
Callback initializes the Signet
client by fetching the
access token and then does some
work with the session,
and then redirects.
Logout basically resets
the session.
Now let me talk about doing
test-driven development with
RESTful web APIs.
You might be asking yourself,
why bother?
Well, the fact of the matter
is code without
tests tends to break.
Whereas robust, well-tested code
is better than fragile,
once-tested code.
It's not really reasonable
to use a RESTful
web API in your tests.
First of all, it'd
be too slow.
It's not very easy to
reset the state on
the third-party server.
There might be quota
issues involved.
And it's hard to cause certain
error conditions to happen.
Last of all, I like to code
on BART, which is
our local train system.
I like integration tests.
That means I'm going to load
pages in my tests that make
use of RESTful web APIs.
So here are some common
reactions I've heard.
Some people say, oh, but doing
test-driven development with
RESTful web APIs is
just too hard.
Or how do you write a stub for
something that you barely even
understand?
Or my favorite, I work
at Pivotal Labs.
I've been doing test-driven
development
since the second grade.
Hurry up and show me
some JavaScript.
Here's my approach to doing
test-driven development with
RESTful web APIs.
IRB is the standard interactive
shell for Ruby.
Pry is an IRB replacement.
I use Pry to start a shell
from within the right
application context.
Play with your app until you
have all the context setup.
And then add binding.pry
somewhere in the code,
probably in a controller
action.
Load the page, and it'll hang.
Now go play around with Pry in
the terminal where you started
rails server.
Use Pry to play around with
the client library.
Make a request and get
a response that
you're looking for.
Then save the output
for later.
Now, as usual with test-driven
development, the goal is to
write some tests and
write some code.
It can be either a functional
or an integration test. Add
just enough code to your
controller or whatever so that
it tries to use the
RESTful web API.
Now do something in your tests
so that it exercises the
controller.
I use WebMock.
WebMock is a library for
stubbing RESTful web APIs.
It'll intercept and prevent your
test from actually making
web requests.
It'll give you a snippet of code
to stub out your request.
Merge that snippet of code with
the real response that
you saved from earlier, And
put it into your test.
Let me share some other
random tricks.
I tend to save the real response
in a file with a
realistic name based on the
original URL that I requested.
You should use these same
techniques to handle all of
your error cases, such as when
your OAuth2 access token
expires or when you don't
get any search results.
Wrap your stubs in functions.
That way you can reuse them
for multiple functional or
integration tests.
In order to simulate an OAuth2
login, look at the tests that
come with the Signet
client library.
Finally, you can use vcr to
automate this whole process.
Now let me demonstrate all the
techniques that I've talked
about so far.
First of all, I have to admit
that there's actually a bug in
my application.
If I search for a video
with a random name,
the application crashes.
It said, no method error.
You have a nil object when
you didn't expect it.
This is the Ruby programmer's
nightmare.
This is a typical bug.
So I'm looking at the code.
And it says, if search_results
sub data, sub items,
.length equals 0.
And it's crashing right there.
Well, obviously, that's
not quite right.
I know that search results is
defined in Quizzes Controller.
So let's go look at that code.
Here in Quizzes Controller, at
the bottom, we have a method
called video_search.
And it defines search results.
Here's the call to fetch
YouTube resource.
I added a binding.pry so that we
could interrupt the request
to see what's going on.
So let's go over here and
back in the browser.
And I'll reload the page.
You'll notice that it hangs.
Back in the terminal where I
started the server, I see that
it stopped on binding.pry.
I'm going to go a little bit
further in code and grab this,
fetch_youtube_resource.
YouTube I'm going to copy that,
go back to the terminal,
and paste it.
Here's the response.
It's a lot of stuff.
But you'll see that there's a
body where it's talking about
the API version.
And we see some data.
I'm going to quit
out of there.
I'm going to type
response.body.
And here's the body that we're
getting from YouTube.
So this is nice because I could
see exactly what YouTube
is returning to me.
I'm going to copy this.
And I'll paste this
into a new file.
Back in quizzes_controller.rb,
there's also a call to
JSON.parse(response.body).
I want to try that out, too.
Because I want to see what
the body looks like
once it's been parsed.
So I'll copy that.
And I'll paste that
into my terminal.
Here we see API version 2.1.
And we see total items. And
notice that we don't see
anything about items, so there
can't be a length.
All we see is total
items is 0.
I'm going to copy and paste
that, too, just because it'll
remind me of what I'm
playing with.
Now I'm going to come
to quizzes_spec.rb.
And I'm going to write a test
that simulates the bug.
So I already have it written
here, but I have
it commented out.
So we have a test that says,
it gracefully handles no
search results.
And this is our spec.
So I'm going to comment
this out.
It says, quiz equals factory
quiz, login, visit
quiz_video_search_url
for the quiz.
Fill in the q with this
random query.
Click the button Search.
And then the page should have
content your search did not
match any videos.
I'm going to go ahead
and save this.
Now, back in the terminal, I'm
going to type rake spec.
You'll see some warnings because
the versions of the
libraries that I'm using don't
perfectly match up.
Now let's look at the
test failure.
It says, quizzes
edit gracefully
handles no search results.
OK, that's the right test.
It says, WebMock, net connection
not allowed error.
Real HTTP connections
are disabled.
This is a sign that WebMock
is doing its job.
It didn't allow my
application to
actually talk to the internet.
The nice thing is it gives me
this little snippet of code.
It says, you could stub
this request with
the following snippet--
stub_request--
and it has a bunch of code.
I'm going to grab that.
Copy.
I'm going to take that back to
my scratch file over here.
And so it says,
stub_request(:get.
And here's the URL that
I was requesting.
And here's the body
that I got.
It shows an empty
body right now.
So I'm going to take that.
And here's the actual body
that I got from YouTube.
I'm going to copy that
and paste it here.
And then I'll do some other
massaging to get rid of the
stuff that I don't care
about, such as
cache control, et cetera.
Back in Quizzes Spec, I have
an edited version of what I
just showed you.
Here's the stub request
for Get.
And here's the URL.
And here's the body
that I expect.
So now we've stubbed out
the request completely.
OK.
Now I'm going to go back
to my terminal.
I type rake spec again.
This time, I get another
failure.
It says, action view
template error.
You have a nil object when
you didn't expect it.
The funny thing is that's
exactly what I wanted to see.
Because I haven't actually
fixed the bug.
I've only written a test
that shows the bug.
Now that we have a test that
exercises the behavior I'm
interested in, I could
go fix the bug.
Now let's look at
videosearch.html.erb.
This is where the original
bug happened.
It says, if search_results,
data, items, .length equals 0.
So this code's wrong.
Instead, let's delete this.
And here's the correct code, if
search_results, sub data,
sub totalItems, .to_i
equals 0.
Let's try running that.
It says, your search did
not match any videos.
So now we know this bug
has been fixed.
But has it been fixed
in our tests?
Let's try that next.
We run rake spec again.
All green, 69 examples,
zero failures.
This bug has been fixed.
And now that my bug is fixed,
my talk is done.
So I'd like to thank
you for listening.
If you'd like to learn more,
go to youtube.com/dev. If
you'd like to follow us on
Twitter, our Twitter handle is
YouTubeDev.
And I'm on Google+.
So you could find me
at gplus.to/jjinux.
Thanks for watching.